well I think that is a wellston divided
as you call it has given us more and
more of an unrealistic sense of
ourselves because we're i think that the
lack of wealth is probably one of the
most dangerous things in our country
today there are a lot of people who are
just too rich I mean they have I
remember you several years ago I I went
to have dinner one night on the yacht of
a very very rich man and he had just
built this boat it was a big huge I
think it was 300 feet or something like
that was enormous it was parked here and
it was a in New York Harbor on the west
side and he gave a dinner party and as
we were as we were leaving the party I I
hitched a ride in a taxi back to East
Side where I lived with a man who was a
he's now passed away but he was a very
successful and very well known a very
wealthy businessman and he was telling
me that this particular man who owned
this yacht who was also very still alive
but it was a very old man at the time
what wanted to get in on another
business deal he was talking about the
business deal he was getting in on and
he was saying you know the problem with
these guys is there just bored because
actually they have more money than they
can spend even the income on but they
just want to make more money because
it's something to do and it's useless
actually it's I think it's just a way of
amusing yourself and I think it's not
particularly positive in any way